now tonight for the hour we're going to
give you news and information no one
else in this media the liberal media
dares to cover and it involves your
national security the evidence is now
becoming more clear every single day now
we're going to get to all of this in
just a minute but first in one of the
most despicable disgusting displays of
politicizing a tragedy that we have ever
seen is now happening now we recently
have watched as Democrats they
politicize every tragedy whether it's
the Vegas shooting or the hurricane
damage in Florida Texas Puerto Rico
Democrats their allies in the left-wing
liberal mainstream media they have now
sunk to a disturbing new low proving
that in their eyes our President
President Trump can do nothing right now
the left in this country is now using
the death of Sergeant David Johnson who
was killed earlier this month in nice
year to attack the President and to do
so the media is using like the number
one Trump hater in the country
congresswoman Frederica Wilson
you know after President Trump called
sergeant Johnson's Widow yesterday to do
the right thing offer his condolences
while congresswoman Wilson who claims to
have heard the conversation said the
President Trump told the widow Widow
that her husband quote knew what he
signed up for and apparently there was
more to the sentence the president
reportedly also said he knew what he
signed up for but when it happens it
really hurts it still hurts the media is
leaving that part out in most instances
now congresswoman Wilson also went to
CNN of course fake news to continue to
trash the president they give everybody
wants to trash the president a forum
over there for calling the widow and the
president offering his condolences watch
this I didn't hear the whole phone call
but I did hear him say I'm sure he knew
what he was signing up for and but it
still hurts I was livid when I heard
that to say that this young man stayed
in school did all the right things went
into the service became a sergeant so
quickly that he signed up for his own
death
that is so insensitive
it is so taken out of context now
President Trump is firing back against
the congresswoman's claims watch this
did you say what that congresswoman said
didn't say it at all she knows that and
she now is not saying it I did not say
what she said and I'd like her to make
the statement again because I did not
say what she said
now congresswoman Wilson's attacks
against the president are not a surprise
she has been vicious from day one
against President Trump going after him
for months
we'll have more on that in a minute
which the media won't tell you but first
let's assume for a second let's let's
assume that maybe the president was
slightly inarticulate in his offer of
condolences to the sergeant's Widow
let's assume for just a second isn't
what the president saying here that
anybody who signs up for the military
they know the danger their courageous
their heroes every brave American who
signs up to defend their country does so
knowing those dangers knowing they may
end up making the ultimate sacrifice
isn't that why we honor military members
because they put their lives on the line
for us every single day in America and
they don't ask for a whole lot in return
isn't that part of the equation sergeant
Johnson to his family our thoughts and
prayers are with you he is a hero
everybody in this country should honor
him for his service and by the way you
have to be a really sick twisted ugly
person but puts politics first which
most of the media is today to think that
the president got up out of bed
purposely got on the phone and wanted to
hurt this family after what happened to
them that's what you would have to
believe to believe this story look I
don't really think the president got on
the phone to hurt the slain soldiers
family he was being thoughtful he was
trying to comfort them and by the way
the White House has witnesses they say
the context of the phone calls what's
important by the way and the congressman
woman what she said well it's only part
of what the president said now there's
also a big question that we all need
answered in all of this is congressman
woman Wilson trying to exploit a tragedy
here and by the way use a tragedy as an
opportunity to attack the president
because it appears she is she's hated
the president from day one no one else's
telling you that in the media this is
not the first time the congresswoman has
attacked the president personally back
in May
she was already predicting president
Trump's impeachment saying quote he
doesn't realize that he is on the brink
of impeachment and people will begin to
call for him to be impeached and the
Republicans will have to join in because
they need to be on the right side of
history and in August Wilson proved she
was no fan of President Trump she
tweeted quote well if you support racist
you're a racist a trill Donald Trump
supports racist because he's a racist
that's what she says about our president
in June she tweeted if real Donald Trump
was a student at a school I served as a
principal and behaved so crudely he'd be
expelled back in March she was pushing
the Russia collusion conspiracy theories
and finally in June in reaction to James
commis testimony she put out a statement
saying quote while Comey described his
impeachment of Justice 101 if all I
heard is true and corroborated by his
former colleagues and the investigation
I believe there's no question President
Trump will be impeached this is the
woman that is leading this cause against
the president who called a widow and one
of the worst moments in her life her sad
lost the sad loss of her child and of
course following right behind the
congresswoman we have all the sheep in
the lap dog media piling on the
president assuming the worst and
president Trump assuming that the Trump
hating congresswoman is correct
they run of course only one side of the
story watch this as usual just put this
into a long list of strange bizarre
interactions that the president has on a
daily basis I mean we could we could
find 10 or 11 or 12 yesterday of public
record we're talking about how he's
incompetent but how about insensitive I
don't think he has any compassion
no empathy President Trump is now
embroiled in a new controversy about
what he said to the widow of Sergeant
Lee David Johnson one of four soldiers
killed in that ambush in Niger every one
of them are phony hypocrites you know
why where was the media outrage when it
was revealed that then President Obama
he didn't even call one of his own
generals now president Trump's chief of
staff general Kelly when his own son was
killed in Afghanistan in 2010 did you
hear anything from any of those people
in the media back then I tend to doubt
it and there's also a 2010 report from a
local Washington paper that says when a
Goldstar parent called the White House
to talk to President Obama he was told
Obama didn't typically make those kinds
of calls
no wonder according to a new political
poll 46% of the American people think
you and the media make up stories about
the president you know why they think it
because it's true you do and of course
it's selective moral outrage once again
now in a few minutes tonight you're
gonna meet a gold star mom Karen Vaughn
she begged President Obama to not bring
cameras when her son was being brought
home in a coffin and President Obama did
in anyway so I'm sick of everyone in the
media all their feigned outrage all
these lawmakers that hate President
Trump and making their living off hating
President Trump like congresswoman
Wilson I have a challenge for all of you
overpaid spoiled brats in the media okay
you care about the family we should
focus on the family and guess what I
heard that this wife is pregnant I'm
gonna personally donate I've already
done it $14,000 you can donate $14,000
tax-free so fake Jake Tapper are you
gonna donate $14,000 and match it
Anderson Cooper what about you you make
enough money what about all you liberals
over a conspiracy TV what about Rachel
Maddow Lawrence O'Donnell you got to
pony up
how about Humpty Dumpty Stelter so I'm
so sick and tired of all of you people
exploiting tragedies believing the worst
and doing nothing to help these people
put up the money also tonight our
and breaking news story the hills John
Solomon has uncovered another massive
Democratic standoff that is raising
serious legal questions about the Obama
administration and the Clintons now here
is a quick overview of what we now know
as this is developing every hour
according to John Solomon and circa news
Sarah Carter in 2009 the FBI uncovered
evidence showing that the Russia Russia
remember Russia Russia Russia Vladimir
Putin that their nuclear industry
officials were engaging in bribery and
kickbacks and money laundering and other
criminal activities we knew about it in
an effort to move and advance vladimir
putin's influence on america's uranium
market then inexplicably knowing all of
this in 2010 while the bribery scheme
was still going on the Obama
administration they went on and approved
the uranium one deal that gave Vladimir
Putin Russia 20% of control of America's
uranium the foundational material to
make nuclear weapons there's also
another major aspect to this story the
hill and circa are reporting that the
FBI has evidence including an eyewitness
account that Russian nuclear officials
quote routed millions of dollars to the
Clinton Foundation while Hillary was
serving as Secretary of State and while
she signed off on the uranium one deal
that gave 20% of our uranium uranium to
Vladimir now tonight the lawyer for the
FBI informant Victoria ton Singh she
says the Obama administration blocked
her client from informing Congress and
the American people about what he saw
happening Victoria will join us at a few
minutes with an exclusive interview but
first here's what we don't know and why
you should be outraged this is what the
media won't tell you according to both
reports the Obama administration they
kept evidence of this Russian bribery
plot secret from Congress and by the way
it's unclear of members of the
government committee the people that
approved the uranium 1 deal for Vladimir
knew what Russia was doing when they
actually signed off on the agreement
there's evidence that shows that may in
fact be true and the Senate Judiciary
Committee has now announced that they
are launching an investigation
into what key Obama administration
officials knew and what they knew when
and for good reason there are several
high-profile officials that were
involved in all of this here they are
former attorney General Eric Holder he
was a member of the committee that
approved uranium one he had to know all
of this and he also headed the
Department of Justice they oversee the
FBI now to me there's no way he didn't
know about this Russian nuclear plot and
he needs to testify under oath what he
knew when he knew it did he withhold
vital national security information then
there's a now Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein and he's now deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe two other people
watch their names they were the only
ones who oversaw the FBI's investigation
into this Russian bribery so there's no
way that they weren't aware of what was
happening so tonight the burning
question is why were they silent why
didn't they sound the alarm about Russia
while uranium was being approved this
deal to give to Putin and by the way
next on the list special counsel robert
muller he was the FBI director back in
2009 when all this probe was going on
the bribery probe you know given what we
now know Muller should not be in charge
of any investigation as it relates to
Russia Russian collusion or election
interference because he has yet another
massive conflict of interest but since
it appears that Muller will be sticking
around maybe he should focus on the
actual evidence of real Russian
collusion everything is here all the
evidence all that Muller and his team
needs to do is corroborate the facts now
today in an effort to be fair to get
answers we reached out to Eric Holder to
Robert Muller Andrew McCabe rod
Rosenstein Bill and Hillary Clinton the
Clinton Foundation we asked all of them
to comment about these explosive reports
the Department of Justice did respond
about McCabe and Rosenstein they stated
quote for long-standing department
policy we don't comment on the existence
or course of investigations the Clinton
Foundation they did get back to us
they're denying the story and big
surprise we didn't hear back from any of
that we reached out to mmm shocker now
the Attorney General Jeff Sessions is
also being asked about investigating
this scandal he was on Capitol Hill
earlier today he was pressed by Senator
Chuck Grassley of Iowa about the Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein watch
this I would like to remind you that
Deputy Attorney Rosenstein directly
supervises the criminal case when he was
US Attorney in Maryland I don't think it
would be proper for him to supervise a
review of his own conduct do you it
would be his decision he's a man of
integrity and ability if he feels that
he has a inability to proceed with any
investigation it would be his
responsibility to make that
determination and should consult as I
told you I would and as I have done with
the senior ethics people at the
Department I'm sorry this is shocking
that the Attorney General is refusing to
flat out say rod Rosenstein needs to
recuse himself if the DOJ opens an
investigation into this Russia bribery
scandal sessions was also asked about
having the FBI having evidence that
Russians kickback money to the Clinton
Foundation he refused to comment on that
publicly now we've been saying this for
months if if the Attorney General
believes in equal justice under the law
he needs to investigate the Clintons
because there's overwhelming
incontrovertible criminal evidence
against them they should not get a free
pass just because they have money named
power and influence that's not how our
system of justice is supposed to work